or who the [ __ ] my ancestors were
wow it's your boy lv general lumpy
slumpy
my brothers don't eat crumpets welcome
back to lv's track of the week
this one's hard this one is sick it's
from one of my people's den
my brother man that kenny all stars
artists on the track is guests
it's on man about bars obviously kenny
all stars this show penny's blessed man
he's a blessed person still and
i like that he's bringing the brothers
through that's forgets
um he had a little old school beef with
one of my brothers in the nsp money big
p but that that that that squashed i
think but i would love to see this
through clash
just for the hype of the game this one's
going to be sick i already know it's
going to be bars and flows and
their action and bear everything can get
me caught guess is sick if i forget
again make sure you're subscribing to
the show
the ones that haven't done that how dare
you subscribe it just takes two seconds
just click this that and sit back and
relax and watch the show
i didn't even know if my voice could
even give enough justice to what you're
about to hear right now
yeah you sure
[Music]
he just speaks different he is a
different guy
massive ancestors now tell me how much
man spit about
any bar and say ancestors please i'm
waiting he's gonna done it again in it
i already know that this is gonna be
fire because he's not even on a hat
when he's relaxed he's dangerous when
he's relaxed
he is what dangerous
my ancestors were [ __ ] off ask me how
i'm doing
just reply i can't complain
[Music]
sky's a madman blood he's spiritually
a different person from a different land
bloody just
he says things what makes you question
what he's saying that's what you want
from music you want to sit down and
listen to certain man
and be like you know what yeah blood
like this guy's deep up
ask me how i'm doing and now just reply
i can't complain
i owe my monsters
[Music]
wow see [ __ ] genius that's why i said
madame have to allow it again
how can man say that you're not you're a
black lives matter but then you're out
there murdering your black brothers
it don't make no sense so you can't even
scream that again blood
he's mad but he's so right
i issues
[Music]
you want to shut down the system but you
don't even reboot it
it's just like turning off your computer
and it's not working there's something
wrong with it so you reboot your [ __ ]
they always tell you hold it 10 seconds
at the back of the computer then it will
reboot for you
and then you can play it again and look
you know what it does when you put on
your router if you turn the router off
10 seconds
put it back on boom everything should be
moving smooth but no
the system's corrupted because they
don't want to reboot
[ __ ] that that's why the system's
corrupted ruby
i said full up the lorry with g-u knits
[Music]
that's 50 in the rucksack i said you're
coming up short man's like now
[Music]
[Music]
certain people don't know what i'm
talking about so you go to someone's
house
yeah with the friends with your crowd of
friends whatever
you bang bang bang and bro see me i was
a [ __ ] little [ __ ]
i was that one will just knock the dog
jump as soon as i know they're coming to
the door
see like they may have pets in the house
you're about to knock your bark you cut
you get me
cause the dog sense danger they're
spiritually different to us
it's all right he ain't getting attacked
he's all right lassie he's all right all
right
chill out now all right all right let's
stop marking the set because he said it
all right okay
okay bring back so much memories
[Music]
because that's not the way that you came
back see what happens when you walk in
the wrong area
that always happens
man's mom sent him shop and he forgot
what he was trying to get for mom like
what did she want again i'll go out and
i see mandem you're right a couple gal
you get me next minute i'm at the shop
i'm like right what's that meant to wear
you forget took the canada goose and
left the credit card in the morning
on my mind right now i'm black and my
problems don't stop there
right now i don't feel too social start
writing
yeah everyone does that i don't do
tweets though i do write stuff and then
i delete it because i just feel like
what
is he [ __ ] gone and done again look
what he's gonna see what i'm saying
what's so far in and he's doing this
again look is it it's the real [ __ ] you
see me it's in a show
it's so real car we don't need to go
with this whole like
that upper class [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying man walk through you might even
have a conversation in the back where
someone's shouting and arguing in a
minute
all right everybody make your noise go
home
we move that's how it works we just move
we don't don't worry we move
let's start right in the tweet
i don't mean that i'm keeping a secret
spin the [ __ ] up yeah but i'm hopeful
if we unite that's a serious achievement
tell em if we unite it's a serious
achievement
it is because that's that'll be amazing
for everyone that will get along
just i ain't too vocal it don't mean i'm
keeping a secret spin the [ __ ] up yeah
but i'm hopeful if we unite that's a
serious achievement hello crabs in the
barrel
it's always me and my own people
competing
what did you mean by that perhaps in the
barrel it's always
my team it's always me and my team
competing so what's he trying to say is
only human in that circle
you actually are the goats you man can
only compete each other so
you man at that level at that level you
can't go past it
suddenly user inside that barrel in that
circle basically
and that's how i take a nap let me know
in the comments what you think in it
yeah because that one day i was a bit
mad still these rock stars comparing
numbers
these old ways out there these youngers
yeah it's true it's true you best fair
what the [ __ ] he says because he's
actually
that guy stubborn witchcraft
smith whenever i spell you should
[Music]
[Music]
okay see you see what i'm saying he
finessed me
i'm so tapped into this thing i wonder
if gets those justin's pain
nan told me keep my head up and walk
around with an adjusted frame
over 10 years deep still just into some
and still adjusting to fame
that's what i'm saying he's living in
free bodies
he's still living that life so i
boom back in the day managed to call man
now i don't know if i can say this still
car that get all
searched afterwards [ __ ] it i used to
call my killer don't i wasn't a killer i
didn't kill nobody
i know it sounds mad when we used to go
out a man used to get into a little
russell or whatever
because things used to happen when he
was young right managed to go
kilo i cannot deal with him how dare you
shout out killer
now they think i'm a killer we might
have someone [ __ ] have a knife or a
gun try to kill me
because they think i'm danger we need to
change it to general or lv or what i'm
trying to say is
where i understand where he's coming
from now where justin and gets
like back then they would call me that
but now you call me this guy so back
then
i don't know i was on the streets man
was doing whatever
but i was still on the straight and
narrow but i was still doing a little
hair in there gamble's era and there
what not
i grew out of that and now i've become a
man i'm more matured
and i've got kids so i've gone on
the right path and it's more happier
more fun you know what i mean and it's
and it's good
oh can justin feel his pain like as if
he's living that lifestyle and plus
his brains telling him stuff like blood
this guy's going through a lot of [ __ ]
you don't even know if he's depressed
we don't know whether he's good bad
trying to let us know through his music
and his bars
that there's a lot going on me keep my
head up and walk around with an adjusted
frame
over 10 years deep still just into some
and still adjusting to fame
so i'm saying this is this ah i said
he's still 10 years deep
trying to adjust to justin's like
justin's trying to adjust the fame
where his guests just get some gets his
on this but justin the guy inside the
one who thinks too
deep is still adjusting to fame this is
where
kenny said i don't even know if what
he's saying even
covers what's about to happen and i get
it
it's not it don't cover it bro this
guy's this guy is a different breed
my music is all i play boy i ain't
accustomed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like i said it's a 10 anyway i should
have to even you not know already that's
a 10.
kenny's laughing off motherboard but
this that shows
sick getz is a deeper guy though usually
man like
he just makes me think like why am i
doing more music like
how i grew where i came from why am i
jumped on this why am i doing it
what was i doing before yeah man he's
the inspiration still
i rate it as well man that we got
yourself even like
letting us tap into that part of you you
know i mean
finding out that you're in a force blood
and what you go
for unicorn there were certain things
you said and i caught it you feel me
we got yourself as well kenny shout out
stan that tv
yeah damn mixtape madness as well before
i forget
you get me cut like i said before
deadman are doing bits
lump it's lumpy my brothers don't eat
crumpets
[Music]
peace
you